this is a production of cornell
university
uh okay hi everyone
so i'm jimmy so i'm very glad to have
this opportunity to present my research
here
so today i'm going to talk about how to
mechanistically estimate photosynthesis
and for the synthetic capacity from
solar industrial calorific fluorescence
by utilizing the physiological
foundations
so first i'd like to
talk about the motivations of this
research
we know photosynthesis is a composed
light reaction and the carbon reaction
during the light reaction and the energy
from sunlight absorbed by the leaves
is is painted is dissipated by three
passwords so the first pathway is to
enter the electron transport chain
and then produce the reduced energy atp
and aadgh
which can drive the carbon benzene cycle
in the carbon reactions
and and the second is patient pathway is
to display the energy as height or known
as knife for the chemical creation
of probated as npq so the third pathway
is to emitted energy as the calorific
fluorescence
so during the whole process of light and
carbon reactions
simple it is the only optically
detectable for the same circle signal
and it's tightly coupled to electron
transport transport which drives the
carbon reactions
so therefore uh the rapidly growing uh
cross scale observations of c f can
offer a promising opportunity to
quantify photosynthesis across different
spatial temporal scales
so with the emerging interest rate in
taking advantage of the information
kylie insists to constrain
photosynthesis
by utilizing the balance between light
and carbon reactions
it's critical to develop an approach
that enable director and independent
estimates of estimates of photosynthesis
so the initial findings have identified
the linkage between safe and
photosynthesis so the first uh flow of
the from the observational side
and the exhilarating studies they have
find the empirical
linkage between uh safe and
photosynthesis uh inferred with the id
covariance members of net ecosystem
exchange
for the synthesis inferred with this way
although often assumed as truth is not
directly mattered but it's indirectly
and precisely derived with approaches
knowing to contain errors or human bias
so the potentially biased photosynthesis
are used as a truth to infer
photosynthesis a sinful relationship
essentially confronting our motivation
in appliances to constraint for
synthesis
and secondly from the modeling side
the existing studies
primarily adopted the scope model
to simulate a safe photosynthesis
relationship
specifically the scope model
firstly utilizes the fvcb by chemical
model
to calculated uh for synthesis
either then for the chemical quantum
yield which in turn is the user to
calculate the chlorophyll fluorescence
yield and then sieve
by empirically linking line for the
chemical quenching models
so while useful for stimulation c for
photosynthesis relationship
but the scope of basic strategy cannot
escape the well-known accident from the
parameters and
structures
for example the direct use of these
levels fvcp by chemical model and the
kennedy skills
will cause the uncertainties and the
larger skills
another uncertainty source is from the
empirical interfere model we know npq is
a knight photochemical quenching is a
very complex parameters it contains
multiple components but here this
empirical model only consider ntq as a
single parameters so that it will
constitute the uncertainties
so also it's
a circular to use the um establish the
thief for the signature relationship to
back calculated photosynthesis
so based on this uncertainties from both
observational and the modeling
side
we we were thinking about
how should we utilize the mechanistic
information content observation
independent from
the exhibition photosynthesis estimation
approaches that are going to have
different different levels of
uncertainties
so here we have a mechanistic light
reaction model with sifu so this model
is
established uh
from a theoretical relationship between
safe and photosynthesis with the actual
electron transport rate as a bridge
specifically this model first utilizing
cf to calculated the actual electron
transport rate with the ql based
equations
here ql is the fraction of open reaction
centers
we also can also use the npq based
formulations to calculate the actual
electron transfer ratio so these two
models these two equations
mechanistic equivalent
but here we only choose qr based
equations
that is because although
the these two equations
are theoretical equivalent
but practically they have different
complexes uh like the uh ql
it reflects the redux state of ps2 and
it's uh is pro and and uh it provides a
steady state um
approximation of
the for the of the steady uh card uh the
cyto cytochrome b6f
that is uh that plays a central role in
the study for the synthesis but npq it
involves both energetic and enzymatic
reactions
um although the height dissipation from
ntq is predominantly localized in the
complex
light harvesting complex
its activation and the regulations
across in the lumen side side of
the lumen and the thylakoid membrane and
stroma
and also ntq has a delayed uh response
to the light variations
it also contains
multiple components each component
operates at different time scales so
this complex activation regulation and
the delayed time response
and the environment of the multiple uh
responses uh of uh of the in the dynamic
of integral components increasing the
complexities in modern npq as compared
to ql
so once the ql versus the actual
electron transport rate is calculated
based on the qr
equations
then the photosynthesis can be directly
calculated with these equations
so from this scheme we can see this
model has a clear separation between
safe and photosynthesis it can avoid the
circularity
issues we mentioned about
to verify this
this models we first
focus on the leaf scales and
collected concurrent members
gas exchange and chlorophyll
fluorescence
from the a variety of species
from the 11 plant plant functional types
native to the temperate tropical and
boreal climates in the corneal botanical
gardens the tropical botanical gardens
and also the working growth chambers at
uh at upgrade national lab
here we thank for the young gender and
health students from the university of
mayor for collecting the data in
tropical species
utilizing this weather sorry here is the
pictures uh for our mermaids in the
botanical uh cornell botanical gardens
so utilizing this wide range of species
we first tested the relationship between
cysts and the photosynthesis we find a
non-linear relationship between safe and
photosynthesis across different plant
species
this non-linear relationship is
characterized by the initial increases
of photosynthesis
at the same
[Music]
leveling of when the light is when the
light intensity is high so this
non-linear relationship is because the
photosynthesis
saturates at the highlight but the
things keep increasing at the highlight
and also we find a different
degree of non-linearity between carbon
steel and carbon four species
this nonlinear relationship can be
explained by our formulations
so here we we can see the
ql the environmental qlql
will prevent the dependence of
photosynthesis on safe
we then tested this relationship under
different temperatures
so we find the similar results
and also different uh
um
different level of uh the saturation is
under the rich approaching the
saturation level amongst carbon three
and carbon four species
so this non-linear relation relationship
is not uh consistent with the patterns
that
at the canopy level that reported a
linear relationship between cf and
photosynthesis
that is because at the canopy level and
beyond
the
canopy structures or all the leaf error
index dominated the
relationship between safe and
photosynthesis but this linear
relationship tends to break down at a
shorter time scales
for example uh recent studies they find
a decoupling between safe and
photosynthesis
when artificially closing the stomata
conductance
by adding the abscisic acid hormone to
so the cluster stomach conductance
will decrease the interstellar co2
concentrations
and then decrease the photosynthesis
and that causes the uh that causes
decreased demand for the reduced energy
atp and adph so to keep the balance
between life and carbon reactions
plants will uh
decrease the
uh
the the ql and or increase mpq to uh
dissipate the excess energy and to
decrease the
production of reduced energy
then we tested the performance of our
model
so this figure can show that
our model can
reproduce the method photosynthesis very
well across different plant plant
functional type species
and also we tested its performance under
different temperatures
it performs still very well
then we tested the uncertainties of our
model
so before showing the results
i'd like to strengthen one point and
that is
our model and as a traditional user svcb
biochemical model or photosynthesis as a
leaf skill is equivalent
so the equivalent is
the equivalent lysis
balance between light and carbon
reactions so the difference between
these two models is that our model is
from the perspective of light reactions
but the traditional used
fvc biochemical model is from the
perspective of carbon reactions
and another difference is that
our model can be used only if the sif is
available
so based on the equivalence we tested
the uncertainties uh these two of these
two models
uh first by you by utilizing the t of
the specific parameters uh we compared
the performance of these two models so
it's fine it
shows
our model performs a slightly better
than the fpcb biochemical models so the
every cb biochemical models
slightly overestimate the photosynthesis
and also we using a multi-color
simulations to test the accelerators of
these two models
the figure a shows that our model
suffers less accuracy at different light
intensities
and also shows a narrower
density distribution of photosynthesis
at the saturation
light
here
the difference is the performance
difference is not due to the model uh
regular negativeness but due to
differences in the uh level of parameter
requirements specifically our model uh
takes advantage of the information
carried in for an essential case the
uncertainties propagated from the
imperfect mode parameterizations
again here we
we compare these two models it's not
because we want to show which model is
better than the other or
which model has a weakness but so we
only
we only want to show that our model
takes a takes advantage of the
information carried in safe
so so that it will decrease
uncertainties for the sentences
estimations
so to further facilitate our model to a
larger skills
we still have some risk
have more works to be that needs to be
done in the future
so first we need to couple or uh leaf
radiative transfer scheme uh or invoke
escape
probability factors to infra the total
sale from pl2 from the remotely
senseless
or we needed to
make and we we needed to mechanistic
model the response
the
response of ql under environmental
conditions
and then exactly estimates the kdf
parameters
um
that requires a development uh
leaf level for spectral uh fluorescence
systems that enable separation ps1 and
ps2 contributions
and eventually we also need to couple
the stomata conductance model and our
model
so that is much like the classical fvcb
by can commodore is applied uh in the
inner tourist territory of bioscale
models on all the lens fill other
language surface
models so here is a simple uh summary
for the about research
so that we we know in the application of
the fecb biochemical models
at the larger scales the parameters like
the vcmx gmax
is the maximum uh carbon oxygen carbon
oscillation rate or the maximum electron
transport rate uh is often assigned a
specific values for for each plant
functional types so that is insurances
will constitute the major source of
prediction errors in the simulating
photosynthesis at the larger scales
we know these two parameters are very
important
and
it can determine for the synthetic rate
and its response to environmental
changes
so that the timely and accurate
estimation of this parameters is
important
so currently the c for emergence as a
promising remote sensing tool to
infrared cmx and the gmax
so we were thinking about how should we
utilizing the safe
to mechanistically modeling
photosynthetical capacities in natural
environments
so the computer studies uh have find the
mixed results
for the relationship between cf and vc
max
for example there there's one study
there's there are first studies they
they first reset the vc methods to
arrange all realistic values
and then using the scope model to
simulate the c4 with mx relationship and
they find a linear relationship the
positive linear relationship between
with mx and the c4
of fixed d
and there's another studies and they
find a new relationship between safe
between c f and v c max or g max but
find a negative relationship between
v c max g max
and c field so here c field is
calculated by the c f divided by
observable uh light intensities
so the negative relationship between and
this max c with c field is attributed to
the uh the linear possible relationship
between g max
and
they didn't consider the
mismatch
with in relation with max to c4
specifically we know the vc max and the
gmax
calculate the photosynthetic capacitance
and
they they
are these suppose two parameters that do
not uh
uh depend on the
the floating fluctuation light and but
the sifu
is emitted only from the light respect
light actions
they very simple rapidly with the
flocculating fluctuating light in the
natural environments
like the seafood uh
increasing with the lighting intensities
and also it has a diagnosis
so to better understand the causes of
the disclaimers of the existing studies
and develop a mechanistical solution to
information x and d max
using thief when we first
started to establish
a theoretical basis that links
electron
that links the with the next gmax
and the sieve
by
balancing the actual electron transport
rate derived by the fpcb biochemical
model and that derived by our our
magnetic light reaction model
so first under the loop is called
limiting status
we can derive the
functional relationship of vcmx
with c4
so here we only derive
with max equations
but a similar relationship of g max with
c
is also is expected
that is because vcmx and the g-max has a
close relationships among different
species and environments
under the iop generation limitation
status we also derived a functional
relationship of g max with c4
obviously max relationship is also
expected
under this limitation status
so in these two equations
we can get two hypotheses so the first
hypothesis is that the same
allowing cannot be used to uh
information max and or d max
but the
the the products of ql and c4 can be
better used to infrared cmx and the gmax
the hypothesis is true is that vc max
and the dmx have different relationships
with
c4 times ql between rubisco limited and
aerobic regeneration limited carbon
oxidation states and that is because uh
in the
formulation or within x with sieve we
can see the slope the parameters in this
slope are often assumed conservative
but uh in the
but either formulation under iot
generation status just the slopes in
contains uh ql safe and power variables
and it will impact the direct dependence
of
gmax or vcmx
on c times ql
so to verify these two hypotheses
we
further feature the
we further fitted the vc max and the
g-max with the traditional approaches
that are defeating steel to response
curves
based on fvcb biochemical models
here we didn't use
use our theoretical equations to
calculate the resonance at the g max
that is because
of the parameters in these formulations
are often assumed as a constant but uh
by the way but they they are currently
unknown so these are some of the
constant values we all uh
caused in accurate vc max and
dmx values
first of if we
use the species from
six plant functional types these
plant functional types we find that
there's no relationship between safe
and vc and the gmax vc max
but
if ql is accounted for
then
there are a significant relationship
between and c for uh times q l with g
max and vc max
and also
qll is significantly related to vc max
and gmax
but compared with the sieve times ql
the explanatory power of ql for vcmx and
gmax is reduced uh by 11
or 30
so that indicates that c times ql can be
used by trading for vc max and the gmax
we further tested this relationship
under different temperatures and we find
the similar results
so that this results can uh confirm our
hypothesis one
so our theoretical and the minimum
results
consistently consistently show that
there's no uh general or predictive
relationship between
safe alone with cmax and
vc max
and our study
focused on the least level so even at
the least level the the relationship is
already complexes at the volcanic level
there are additional complexes
such as the structure the canopy
structure and the reabsorption of this
within the tempest and all the vertical
variation of ql
will impact the strength of the
relationship between steve along and vc
max gmax
and also from our theoretical
equations we
is
is
and wanted mechanistically
expect a simple relationship
between between gmx vcmx and safe alone
so this can explain the conflicting
results in existing studies
another findings is that
uh the
um
the link the the
really the close relationship between
gmax with max with safe uh whole
relative was stable
among temperatures
so to understand
uh to understand it we compared the
temperature dependence of vcmx gmx and
qlc4
so we find the vcmx gmax and ql has a
similar patterns with temperatures
but the temperature but the temperature
has a
slight
uh has a weaker
impact on
this so the basic max d max ql they
increase
in parallel in parallel as functional
temperatures from the 12
from the 20 to 35 degrees and then it
decreases decreases at a higher
temperature
and also we find a linear relationship
between vcmx and ql so that can be that
combine
that might suggest
the ql can
infer
can reflect the
[Music]
activation
of carbon oxidation enzymes
then we further tested the hypothesis
too we find that the linear relationship
is uh
is stronger under rupees calamity design
under iodine generation limited status
that's start when see if times ql is
used to inform c max and the g maps
we need a priori information of which
which carbon oscillation
limitation status synthetic
so here we can use the response of
actual electron transport rates uh
on um
two lightning tends to
identify the limitation status
so for example if the actual electron
transport rate is in is increasing with
the power then the data belongs to the
iob generation limiting status
but if the actual electron transport
reach a planet's planetary
with par then the data is lubitsco
limited
so here interestingly we find the sieve
times ql has a similar pattern with the
actual electron transport ratio so that
means if the qll is magnesium modeled
and then the c for times ql at the
canopy level and beyond
it can be used to
identify
the carbon oscillation
limitation status
so here here is the similar patterns
can be also
explained by our theoretical equations
so that means the ql times ko can be
directly used to calculate the actual
electron transport rate
here is a brief summary so first the
safe alone is incapable of informing the
evaluation of the universe max
and
even when safe is determined under the
same environmental conditions
secondly our following suggests that the
redux state of ps2 reflected by kl
strongly influences the relationship of
genesis and with the next cmx
the limitation state of carbon
oscillation must be considered if
observed 6 is utilized to infrared max
and dynamic environmental conditions
so here we thank for the contributors on
our research
thank you that's it
yeah thank you very much teammate
um
any questions from the audience
feel free to unmute yourself and ask
questions directly or post your question
to the chat window
well ying i this is not my area at all
but um
so i was looking it seemed like a lot of
the relations i saw
at the higher concentrations
of either sif or
assimilation or whatever you you had
much larger spreads in it the lower ones
seemed to be a common thing in a lot of
these scatter plots was i seeing that
correctly may oh and what what what
explains that
i don't know which slide you had a lot
of slides where you're
you're showing this relation and at the
higher at the higher levels there would
seem to be much more spread a lot of
little gray dots
and when you were got down to lower
concentrations you had
much less
error it seemed to be a kind of funnel
shape
i don't know if i saw that correctly
yes uh that's a good questions
um
yeah we yeah our study from the leaf
scale but we know only at the leaf scale
the uh functional process can be fully
investigated
and
and uh and even at the least scale uh we
know the
the uh the
maybe the the relationship is already
complexities or
so
i mean at the chemical level except
except the
physiological factors
there are additional complexity
complexities so it will affect the
relationship
um
okay that wasn't really my question but
that's okay
i guess i didn't make it i didn't make
it clear enough
i feel some of you are scattered
tim tim you probably can see that better
than i can so i'll let you go ahead
i'll let you know physiologists talk
here
yeah but actually my question is very
simple and i
i just was going to ask uh you to
maybe tell us a little bit more
background
on uh what is ql actually evaluating
you say that it is the redox state
of photosystem two
so could you just uh spend a little bit
of time to explain further
what is ql
uh
telling us what is ql
yes ql is the fraction of open reaction
centers in ps2 yeah either it can
reflect the redux state of ps2
and off and also uh
it reflects uh
so
uh
it it can
varies with
both light and carbon reactions
uh i mean
[Music]
it can reflect the balance between light
and carbon reactions
okay
so so
what you're what's uh in a very simple
way it sounds like ql is helpful
in telling us whether we are in a light
limited situation
or a carboxylation and co2 limited
situation
is that correct
maybe not yeah i i i yeah tim i think
that is a
quite uh accurate
um summary
um
uh ql so i mean the the take home
message in the second part is that civ
itself
is at at least
from the at verifying scale
uh civ itself is
not sufficient
to
infer photosynthesis or vc max these key
parameters but if we can
borrow the information content
in ql
then we can do a much better job
so basically the carboxylation limiting
stage whether it's rubisco limited or
light limited that information is
implicitly
contained in ql
and that information should also be to
some degree content in sif
but uh again not enough to
directly infer
um
uh the uh
the the v max
is is that clear yeah that's great i'm
i'm uh yeah that sounds great thank you
yeah thank you that's a really great
question thank you
david i would like to uh share my
thoughts of uh to answer your questions
uh i think your observation is
absolutely correct it's just like on the
at the high end
uh there are uh more
uh
um
environmental factors that work together
to influence their relationships
but at the low end it is typically
dominated by
um
a single
environmental factors so that means
the the relationship is going to be
be more complex at the higher end that's
why you'll see more scatters
because we can only show relationship in
2d um plot that's why the influence from
other factors is just basically hidden
there and create more scatters or more
spread does that make sense that makes
that makes perfect sense i was thinking
of something like
like that yeah yeah because at the lower
it's only dominated by one process yeah
i know there were quite some graphs like
that thanks
and then you wonder how do you you just
wonder if that one the other just
statistically speaking when you look at
that one-to-one line
yeah you're fitting it but there's it's
not uncertain the same uncertainty
throughout the whole line so it's really
not exactly
correct in explaining i mean the the
overall error is more concentrated than
one part of it that's all
so yeah yeah yeah yeah it is very
complex so that's why we have to
consider additional uh factors we do
have like a 3d plot i'm not sure if she
may have shown that before uh
in her slides but yeah we do want to
highlight the complexity for some reason
reviewers do not like
the 3d map so we had to convert to
2d um yeah okay that's clear thanks a
lot yeah thank you
any questions
if no other questions thank you very
much uh jimmy for this uh great
presentation
um
so um well hope gmail will have a
successful career um um in the future
once she returned to china yeah thank
you
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu